Luke and Becca here with the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel and we're taking
our family on a nine-day adventure in
the Southwest United States we're going
to be hiking in the snow exploring caves
discovering ancient ruins destroying
cars with excavators off-roading through
the desert camping and so much more
all right guys we're in Salt Lake City
Utah we've got the whole crew in the car
here and we're gonna drive about three
hours south to Moab Utah you guys ready
yeah
all right let's do it jazz hands
well okay we're just a little north of
Moab
[Music]
and we're gonna see if we can't find
some fossilized dinosaur footprints
I got a pockets
there's the foot there's the foot and he
drags the tail behind it
oh yeah you could totally see him looks
like a big huge bird just walked through
the mud
track it's a theropod because it has
three toes thanks Dino Dana Irene serpis
early Cretaceous yeah you can see right
there there
ankylosaurus see it right there see
broad to POTUS they look like huge
depressions like you can see where the
mud's squished really good isn't this
knee just kind of sitting there on the
side of the road
oh this is like the Raptor that that's
really good for friends that thing had
really long strides
dramaosaurus tracks oh they've got the
big claw on it that's cool
oh
yeah man you guys ready to go find some
dinosaur bones
theropod bone oh yeah yeah see right
here that's the vertebrae hey guys you
want to know how a dinosaur takes a
selfie he used a camera asaurus
there's the leg bone of the camera
source
see there's another piece right up there
you can see it those are the vertebraes
right there there's a couple vertebrae
that looks like some fossil right there
oh look at this this is Tony bone right
here see right there
that is totally bone right there
right there look at this whole layer of
it the body
because here a bone used to be right
here and it got pulled out
hey check this out I think this is
petrified wood you can kind of see the
Grain and it just looks like a rotten
log
IC oh
so apparently these are the ruins of an
old Copper Mill some old old tin can
up
I think this is the coal they used to
smelt the copper
oh yeah I could see it the indigenous
people that lived here thousands of
years ago like the Anasazi and stuff
would go up and do little graffiti
writings up on the Rocks there's the
mountain goat right there
Little People they've drawn all right
let's keep going there's more to see
so there's a rock right up there that
has some dinosaur footprints you can
make out and then up there right along
the bottom of the cliff there's some
petroglyphs
I made it it's a theropod footprint
right there
and there's another one right there hey
there's mom and the boys
[Music]
welcome to Monticello Utah
we rented ourselves a little house here
we're gonna use it as a home base as we
explore the surrounding areas
kids are having a great time already
let's go out to dinner
open
it
look at that
it's amazing that was really good
well tomorrow I'm going on a bit of a
hike to go explore and abandoned Native
American city I'm pretty excited about
that so uh I gotta get packed
all right guys it's late we got little
kids we need to get to bed I'm gonna see
you guys in the morning
well if you guys get up and get dressed
we'll get you Donuts all right everybody
in the car
we're gonna stop at the market and get
some breakfast
[Music]
oh these Donuts are warm
hurry grab a donut here you got the box
[Music]
give me kisses I love you guys will you
be good for Mama yeah
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna be doing an 11 and a half
mile hike through a series of canyons
and rumor has it that there's dozens of
untouched ancient Native American
archaeological sites in this Canyon
which we can explore
ah
take it out there's some ruins right
there
so this is the dwelling homes of the
Anasazi Indians the anasazis would find
these outcroppings under these Cliffs
and they would build their homes here
they'd take this flat stone that's
everywhere and stack it up and put mud
in between it and build homes out of it
they take these Cedar beams and sticks
lay them in a crisscross pattern with
mud over the top there you go you've got
a cozy little home a lot of these
structures like this one were greeneries
and they would take the surplus food and
preserve it and put it in here and then
they would wall it all up and they'd
just fill this up with rocks and then
the animals couldn't get to it look at
this
there's a little piece of pottery right
here this could be a thousand years old
I'm just gonna go ahead and put that
right back
now this looks more like a building
because there's like a window and a door
oh that's cool
this is just amazing this has been here
for hundreds of years and nobody's
managed to destroy it or fence It Off
oh
this is cool hey look at this look what
I found
this is the center of the Indian corn
cob
look at that
I just leave that right there
pieces of charcoal left over from their
campfires here
that is cool
well that was way cool but we've got a
lot of ground to cover and a lot more
cool stuff to explore
oh that's Steve
oh
yeah nice little Cactus Thorn right in
the top of my foot I've already pulled a
few thorns out of my legs
ah so cool tell you what this place is
dessert I haven't seen a single person
all day
check it out there's some more ruins up
there
I'm taking my backpack off of this one
it used to be a pretty good sized set of
ruins here and these rocks broke off the
cliff face and smashed it
all right
look at this
oh look at this a whole bunch of more
right down there
oh wow
look at Dinosaurs the Indians Drew this
look at all these drawings
these might be as much as 2 000 years
old
look at the little hand prints they did
look at that I wonder what the rhyme and
reason to this artwork is I mean these
figures don't have heads
but this one's got nipples
check out these corn cobs the anasazi's
would grow corn and store it here that's
hundreds of years old
I was reading up a little bit on the
history of this place before coming here
and apparently while the last known
occupants of this place around 1200 A.D
there's been people that have been here
for thousands of years prior to that you
see all these big rocks that have fallen
down I bet there was a huge ledge that
was all along here because look there's
paintings all the way up there I have
got to get going I am not making very
good time because I keep stopping and
exploring all the time
I wonder how many of these things have
walked right past look at all these
Canyon walls up here
it could be a whole City's hiding up
there that I just missed
oh
that was graceful
foreign
sets in two and a half hours and I'm
about a quarter of a way through the
hike I have stopped and smelled the
roses a bit too much there's so many
interesting things to see so I need to
keep my head down and make some tracks
right up there in the cliffs I can see
some more ruins oh I just don't have
enough time
Hey look
a tumbleweed
see some more ruins in the cave up there
look at that that is really in good
shape
that is so cool but I've got to get
going
I know there's a storm coming tonight
and I can feel it in the wind now
check it out I can see some ruins and
petroglyphs up there can you go check
them out
oh
look at that
this
yellow window on
this see a bunch of sticks they put up
vertically together and caked it with
mud
cool
look at this
another little bit of pottery
so cool
shards of pottery see where they kind of
made a cool pattern on one side and it's
smooth and concave I'm glad I made time
for this one but I've got to keep going
we need to make some tracks Before
Sunset
there's another set of ruins up here
this one's really special
look at this
look at that piece of pottery
that is so cool look at all these
look at all these pieces of pottery
look at this
you get a much better feel for what
these houses look like when they were
intact got the headlight out let's see
we got like a little fireplace right
here in the middle
you got a little smoke hole at the top a
shelf to foot stuff
oh
I think we got to do it I think we gotta
go down here
all right
oh I think that's a lot of pack rat
urine and poo that's really gross
they've got these logs supporting the
roof
and all this grass and stuff in between
you check it out they've got a little
hole to let air in when you have a fire
down here
oh we gotta move fast
all right looks like we gotta climb up
some rocks
foreign
I've done about four miles since and now
I'm just climbing out of the canyon Just
One Last push I'll get up on the plateau
and then I'm gonna find a spot on Camp
all right I made it and I found a nice
flat spot
you know I was feeling pretty warm until
I stopped moving I think it's time to
make some warm dinner
foreign
oh I've been looking forward to a hot
meal all day
that hitting the spot
oh my shoulders are sore from holding
that backpack
but man I want to go to sleep
and uh
and call it a night yeah
oh good morning
eating a cup of moderately warm instant
oatmeal on a winter compound this
reminds me of camping as a kid so much
it's really not that good
foreign
broke down now we need to go find the
PATH it's somewhere over here but you
can see with the snow makes things
tricky
I made it
and most importantly I didn't keep my
wife waiting
[Music]
oh gosh
hey boys how you doing I'm glad you're
driving
oh it feels good to sit down
all right guys should we get up some
lunch
Oh my legs
to Becca that's the honey chicken pizza
you like your pizza okay
[Music]
all right we're at Arches National Park
just a little bit north of Moab Utah
[Music]
we're gonna seize the marches hard here
hello
if you like big pretty rocks that are in
funny shapes Arches National Park's the
place to go me and Tommy were here at
Arches National Park not too long ago is
that right Tom yeah
me and Tommy hiked and camped every
National Park in Utah and did a video
about it but this is the first time for
you guys isn't it
the national parks in Utah can be
incredibly crowded in the peak Seasons
but you come here in the winter man you
got the place to yourself
mmm
pretty
good hey everybody
[Music]
this is double Arch
well guys this is a place called the
windows and this right here is double
Arch because there are two arches yeah
it's a lot sketchier getting down and up
wait I
got this no you good
yeah there you go
this is cheap let's go down to Mama
she's been waiting very patiently
any help
no all right you got it a lot of legs
well we only have about an hour before
Sunset so let's keep moving see what
else is in the park
all right guys we've got another little
hike here who wants to go on a hike
who wants to stay in the car
[Music]
okay I'll stay with the Party Poopers
here's here's a map of the GoPro
of so it comes to being cold or being
left alone with Dad they don't know
which one they'd rather do
it I'll come too yeah no
you guys find some diarrhea
all right so this is a hike called The
Devil's Garden and we're going to go to
Pine Tree Art
thank you
come on just do it like Nathan did
hey babe what do you think has this been
fun love it so you head back to the car
you need help
well the sun's sitting I think it's time
to head back to the house
all right guys we're back at the house
we got a whole bunch of Thai food I am
looking forward to just hanging out
eating food and doing nothing
[Applause]
well guys I'm exhausted and I've got a
mango curry with my name on it so I'm
gonna put up this camera and I'll see
you guys in the morning well good
morning today is a very special day what
day is it my birthday
you're five yeah
oh yeah oh
happy birthday buddy
we're four by fouring through the snow
in the desert is this crazy yeah yeah
Becca's showing off her superpowers
check it out guys it's Bluff fort
[Music]
y all right guys we're just here in
Bluff Utah and there's a old military
fort we're gonna check out
no say thank you thank you look at that
that is that is a diet cone right there
there we go
so this is the bluff fort museum the
descendants of the Pioneers who made
this fort bought the land and rebuilt
the fort and it's just a free museum on
the side of the road
you're in the wagon
here let me hold this for you
an amateur surge is this is this a
pretty slick uh Camp setup
at the cooking pot not a chamber pot
yeah is that a big kettle
the statue of a nine-year-old girl and a
five-year-old boy who traveled from
Denmark to emigrate with the pioneers
and so apparently their parents couldn't
afford to come with them so they went by
themselves that's like Tommy and Jacob
traveling from Denmark all the way to
here in the deserts by themselves that's
insane
oh look at these log cabins it would
take two small pieces cut a bangly and
then put a dowel through it so you got
logs and straw Up on the Roof
howdy
my legs are sore
hey there
how did you do that
yeah that was kind of a cool little
Museum that was neat
foreign
the land of the Navajo Nation now
apparently we're driving down the road
where they filmed a scene from Forrest
Gump
I had run for three years
so we're here at Monument Valley in the
Navajo Nation
[Music]
now apparently if you just want to drive
through I think you can pay to get in
but if you want to get out of your car
and actually explore it you need a guide
for most of the natural wonders of the
Navajo reservation you can't just go out
and explore it you have to have a local
certified guide go with you you got to
be babysat
all right so this is Monument Valley
this is where the Wiley Coyote Road
Runner Cartoons were filmed
you this song
[Music]
okay
you keep blowing me out I keep holding
you in
I keep asking myself
it's cool right that's cool it's bigger
than I thought yeah it was a lot bigger
than I thought that took about an hour
and a half to go all the way around I'm
starved you guys want to get some food
all right let's get some food all right
well boy
get off something
look at that
that is a massive slab of Navajo
flatbread with a bunch of Sandwich stuff
in there that's gonna be good that is a
big Navajo taco there if you guys like
deep fried bread you're gonna like this
really full that is that is huge
apparently over there is John Wade's
cabin from the movie Stagecoach yay
more
alright guys Welcome to Arizona yay
[Music]
well Jake is it your birthday today yeah
is it time to open up a present yes
open it up
this artist come here it's a shark
sleeping bag
yeah you're fighting the shark fight the
shark you need to put on some party hats
I
ah happy birthday dear Jacob
Okay who wants some surprise cutter cake
all right guys it's time to party like
it's 19.99
[Music]
happy birthday my big five-year-old
all right hop to bed guys well we've had
a wild party but it's late I'm putting
up the camera I'll see you guys in the
morning well I woke up this morning to
find my bed empty
and the next bag of empty
turns out everybody was partying over
here you guys got some serious Mama
snuggles going on hey Jacob Jacob are
you gonna wear a birthday hat to do
breakfast okay will you put on a second
birthday hat
just in case the first one falls off or
hey
put it don't sit it everyone's eat as
much as you want pack your bags we got
there's Lake Bell guys yeah wow that is
way down the water level looks like 60
feet low I know they're having serious
droughts besides
well we left Page Arizona and we're
headed west towards Kanab Utah
foreign
it's a gummy snake look at this log as
my arm
no
have a snakehead
is that really chewy huh like chewing
hard candy
all right welcome to Kanab
[Music]
yeah see up there the cliffs that's the
caves we're trying to get to
all right we'll see if we get the kids
up there
all right looks like it's gonna be a
little bit slick mom and Jake are gonna
stay back here
see some are going up above
okay you see how you got this little lip
gonna switch up to it you got it
if this was warm dry weather this path
would be pretty simple but it's the ice
really makes it complicated
[Music]
yeah look at this let's get going for it
hey Rebecca
look there's Mama down there hi Becca
oh
look at this this hole goes back there
for I feel like there's a little cave
within the cave
okay they shut the wall keep walking
I know
and then like the accident
um
oh
okay
you guys ready to go inside the dragon's
belly
yeah you can go that's a nice spot where
you going
it's cold and rainy we decided to
explore a few more caves and uh so this
is the dragon's belly we're gonna take
it out
a lot of names scratched into the side
of this little tunnel
check it out people have been scratching
their names into the walls of this thing
forever all names upon names
well it's not a bad activity when it's
raining yeah
was that a cool little cave
who wants to check out a Sly Canyon me
me who does not want to go hiking me
come on Tom
oh
Southern Utah and Northern Arizona are
just full of hundreds of canyons to
explore including that one right down
there that's Elkhart Cliffs Canyon you
got to go all the way down and around
coming back up is going to be a beast
this is gonna be really unpleasant going
back up
this Canyon is what we call a Slot
Canyon they're super cool but if they
ever fill with rain they become a death
trap flash floods are a real issue
back nowhere either the water would take
you
oh
yeah that's a work
okay and then
[Applause]
get up all right Tom
oh
the water when it comes through here is
so powerful it pushed this rock into
that spot yeah with your foot right
there and stand up
I'm so glad I kid this is so cool I'm a
little nervous about how everybody get
back
whoa
that's pretty cool huh
[Music]
we should probably not leave mom alone
with the kids for too long huh yeah all
right let's head back
whoa
okay you gotta slide okay too much speed
yeah you got it holy smoke does that
work
high fives
yeah
now if this is something you want to do
there are dozens of guides and tours
around the area that'll take you into
these slot canyons with all the
equipment and everything that's
something I highly recommend if you get
a chance
right
where am I
[Music]
all right me and Nathan are here at
Coral pink sound Dunes State Park in
Utah and we're gonna check out the
massive pink sand dunes the largest sand
dunes in Utah
that's the coral pink sand dunes
oh well apparently you can rent sand
boards and sand sleds and go and sled
down the sand dunes but we decided to
come in the middle of a freak snowstorm
Nathan's bombed he was really looking
forward to the sand sled
you know
[Music]
nice
yeah
that's that's nice
look at that
I don't have a clue what's up here
we're all settled in we ordered some
food gonna have it delivered and we're
taking it easy and it feels magnificent
not a bad way to end a long week isn't
it
oh I love you baby
you're missing it too
th right here I wrapped it up in this
did mom hit you no I eated it on my face
Nathan Jacob come down for breakfast
all right guys you want to go swimming
yeah
it's like 45 degrees out we're going
swimming
the heated pool that they use in the
winter time but check this out this is
the pool they use in the summer this
thing is massive it's like the size of a
couple city blocks I think the boys are
content to just be in a warm pool
for me
foreign
hey guys was that fun
here you go Bud all right guys come on
get your shoes Get your coats we're
leaving go go go well today is New
Year's Eve and we are going to visit
some friends
you have arrived
we're celebrating New Year's with the
MacArthur family who are very good and
old friends of ours 25 years ago to the
day I landed in Japan to serve two years
as a missionary for my church there and
the macarthurs were my mission
presidents it's great to meet some old
friends and celebrate the the holiday
with them and the kids are absolutely
having a ball
[Music]
hey guys you want to roast some
marshmallows
you guys having a good new year
[Music]
pool party
one
Happy New Year
[Music]
thank you Happy New Year
oh my goodness
oh that was quite a party Becca I'm a
little tired
oh well we're just slowly getting up and
getting dressed and getting the troops
off to church
all right all right guys we're headed to
church it's late I'm putting the camera
down I'll see you in a little bit
all right everyone at church was asking
us where we're from and Jacob says we're
from America
that must mean we've been traveling
internationally a bit
just going back to our friend's house to
have dinner and just spend a low-key
Sunday
hey well you guys throw the most insane
parties I gotta tell you what well thank
you guys we'll see you you're welcome
and make sure to come up to Alaska say
hi okay
thank you okay love you very much it's
been a great joy to have you it's been
wonderful well good morning it's a
beautiful day and we're checking out of
our little condo here
cold all right all right we're leaving
St George and heading into the deserts
of Nevada we're going to be doing some
4x4 in and exploring and we're going
camping tonight
all right guys welcome to Nevada
desert this is the largest desert in
North America
[Music]
it's a cactus
oh
I just will be away I think that that
comes from that plant
it's a piece of cactus wood
check it out that's a Joshua Tree where
the streets have no name
we're just driving on this wash we see
these petroglyphs up there it's like a
little lizard and a man and some other
things you guys want to ride in the bed
well check it out I think this is a rock
formation called little Finland all
right guys you ready to keep going
exploring yeah all right let's do it
[Music]
all right guys I think this is it
so we're looking for seven Keyhole Slot
Canyon we're gonna go try to check that
out should be somewhere in this rock
formation yeah
look up with the Rocks there might be
some petroglyphs up here see right up
there there's just a little patch of
them right there in the dark stuff
lots of petroglyphs right in here look
at that there's even more over here
deadly
oh yep look at this
so this is seven Keyhole Slot Canyon
check it out so apparently there's seven
Keels can you guys find all seven
there's two right there
in fact I need a free
contests
[Music]
John look at this is this cool
what do you think babe is this cool
it's kind of one of the few chances to
go check out a slight Canyon without
tons of people around and it's right by
the road yeah
oh yeah look someone did a little foot
there I wonder what's down this dark
cave
terrifying
oh yeah look at that somebody scratched
something into the wall right there
you can see this this looks like a bug
[Music]
it's some stuff yeah I don't know what
that is
[Music]
oh yeah yeah that's pretty it is a
flower I can see I could see it yeah
thousands of years ago bored teenagers
graffitied this cave now it's history
and art
so look at that there's a bird nest I've
been trying
oh
it's it's a nice super hot yeah it is a
nice little Hut
foreign
[Music]
Anakin I got The High Ground well guys
should we get back to the car before it
gets dark and we lose the path we don't
want to get lost in the desert
it's hard to see but there's a canyon
behind that big rock and another Canyon
over there I think we could spend days
exploring this and have a great time
doing it
foreign
this might be a decent camps fight pull
those rocks out make a fire pit
here Tom
will you help with the wood
you get yelled at
it
step out on your booting
there you go here I got my knife I undo
all the plastic on all of this wood be
really careful make sure no one's around
you
what do you think Bob is this nice very
scary
really good temperature
cut it like that there you go so let's
start laying down pieces of bread
it's over there
all right I'm heating up some chicken
noodle soup I'm cooking grilled cheese
sandwiches we're gonna have a good
dinner tonight oh these are perfect
okay grab a plate grab there's a big
pile up
please put it on a plate
it's called ladles oh there you go there
you go what do you think you like the
grilled cheese sandwich and soup
pretty good huh Becky you look adorable
eating that you're sweet
so good and nice and warm Makita grilled
cheese sandwich lots of butter lots of
cheese
what you got there babe
Madeline dipped in hot apple cider and
it looks so good
[Music]
Jacob you want a marshmallow they're a
strawberry flavored marshmallow that's
straight shaped like a strawberry
hey
mine's on fire oh you hear that crunch
on that shell you like that Nathan yeah
you want a sword Jake
okay we're gonna put a marshmallow stick
in a cup
there you go
there's your there's your fencing foil
that's what
yeah Three Musketeers
we gotta get you guys ready for bed
oh
there you go right there in the chest
rubbed off
I found this at the store and I bought
it for Becca it's a laugh warmer lasts
up to eight hours and the thing weighs
about a pound it's like the equivalent
of like 10 hand warmers so I'm gonna
throw this in her sleeping bag tonight
it's not that cold tonight it's cold
40 degree degrees but I think everybody
will be a warm tonight I think I think
we'll keep everybody more toasty are you
gonna get on out in there there you go
he got a tow Barber on your butt
yeah keep your crack orbit
just sitting here brushing my teeth I
can see a little kangaroo rat or
something peeking out at us see the long
long tail oh aren't they cute they're so
fluffy oh there he is winning a little
bro over there those things are really
cute they're just little puff balls with
these super long tails and these big
hind legs they just could go
I got two liters of boiling water here
we're gonna put this in Becca's back
put that inside your sleeping bag
there you go put it put it inside your
sleeping bag
are you warm in there
okay
you're like a trapdoor spider
all right buddy I'll see you in the
morning
well me and Becca got the kids to bed
and it's a couple hours before our
bedtime and we're just hanging out here
by the fire listening to audiobooks and
chatting and it's just a wonderful night
I'm just grateful it's not raining and
it's above freezing those are just two
big things for me I'm just glad that we
got that
all right thank you is it time for the
massive hand warmer
you look at that
hold everybody
it's enormous oh I'm so excited should
we go hit the SAG sure let's do it
here we go Becca look at the seal it's
cute
always touch back in we're gonna see if
she can survive the night I'm gonna put
the camera up and we're gonna see you
guys in the morning
hey baby sleep okay
I was warm all night I did not sleep
well it was very windy about an hour and
a half after we went to bed this this
winded rainstorm came in and it just
about flattened the tent I heard the lid
to our pot get blown through the air and
down the hill
get up and start getting some breakfast
babe
foreign
yeah we want that back
is it Jacob awake
yeah see how the boys are doing
you okay oh boys are alive and well
foreign
yeah that's a good looking bacon there
Becca's getting out of the tent got to
get her hot apple cider ready
good morning Mama do you like a plate
and some hot apple cider
here's Mama's plate oh my goodness
that's beautiful here's here's some
Cutlery and there is your hot apple
cider I poured a little while ago so it
might be getting close to the right temp
let's see let's see that's gorgeous
that's amazing
why don't you guys come out there's
french toast and bacon waiting for
everybody maple syrup well I don't mind
if we do right whipped cream
there we go
over your world
we're just about finishing up breakfast
and uh it's starting to rain on us again
we've been traveling the Southwest for
eight days now and all but one of those
days we have been snowed on or rained on
all these rumors you hear about the
desert being hot and dry completely fall
very wet and cold
well I think we better get in the car
because we've got a long way to 4x4 and
we've got to go to Las Vegas so Becca
can destroy a car with a backhoe it's on
the to-do list today it's on the to-do
list
foreign
[Music]
dig this just a little south of Las
Vegas and uh we're gonna do a little
heavy equipment party here and let all
the boys try operating heavy equipment
there my name's Phil
yeah
hey are you excited Jake
one two three
I got this you do it a lot
controls you can reach them Bud
let's get some power guys
yeah there we go you ready Jake yeah all
right like this and this very nice right
joystick left like you're eating
something gorgeous you just did your
first bucket in the backhoe is that cool
yes there you go
this one
well I'll tell you what Jacob was an
absolute natural at the backhoe he did
really good so right now Tommy and Nader
in the skid steers and there's knocking
over tires and stacking them up the
whole family has a radio set so we can
hear what's going on over there
oh yeah
all right I'm gonna show you guys how to
lose some dirt you guys ready to move
dirt I need to go forward a little bit
more
I'll give you a high fives
all right guys so next Becca's gonna get
to destroy a minivan with a backhoe
there we go this is the pirate car now
oh the platform of Destruction you ready
to watch Mom destroy a car
this is gonna be awesome
[Music]
thank you
good job you have fun good job
Jake what do you think of this
you look great babe
turn off the antenna of the car there
you you keep that don't let the boys
take that forever
you saw this out right here hey you
wanna you wanna get a plaque to put in
your room Nate yeah I think it was that
fun that was so fun oh you were so cute
doing that
all right those guys were so good with
the kids listen if you guys want to do
this too check out dig this in Las Vegas
I'll put a link to their website in the
video description below all right Becca
should we head back to Salt Lake let's
head back to Salt Lake has this been a
good trip yeah yeah it is I'm glad we
did this together
well we made it to Salt Lake and
everyone's safe and sound and we have
had a wonderful trip hopefully you guys
have enjoyed this video if you want to
see more of our travel Adventures make
sure to check out our travel Adventure
playlist we have videos from travel all
over the world and if you enjoy this
type of video make sure to click
subscribe to the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel we put out new videos every
Saturday morning if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
Boys YouTube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]